wie es bei dir die bei mir ist die lage
sehr entspannt das sind sessel in denen
man sich ein wenig ist die lage
phänomenal
aber du hast kein album rausgebracht
machtwechsel gehst auf tour
wie ist die lage so sehr gut ich schon
jetzt 25 ersten wie dieses liegt ja
jetzt schon ein bisschen was zu rücken
sechs wochen oder so wir haben 120
erreichten gut gestartet in der sehr
starken woche wünsche mir sagen ich war
einer der stärksten wochen bis jetzt im
jahr
jetzt steht die erste solotour an wir
haben es ein bisschen klein gehalten ich
bin jetzt fünf sechs konzerte im april
werden auch weitere fünf sechs konzerte
spielen dann irgendwann im september
oktober
und ja ich bin guter dinge dass wir uns
jetzt langsam langsam immer weiter
aufbauen
wann ist das erste album ist erschienen
bei der da meine aller erstes album ist
ein zwei jahre 2011 2011 22 jahren aber
du hast mit rappen angefangen wann ich
mache schon rap lang nur muss man halt
unterscheiden zwischen rap machen und
professionell die ganze sache angehen
und dann auch noch einmal zwischen
professionelles machen können aber
nichts machen und wirklich loslegen
nochmal umdrehen und ja richtig 0 also
dass ich jetzt dieses ganze ding pelé
sports mich als rapper und so aber auch
halt irgendwie als ein geschäft und ein
projekt betrachters seit ende 2010 so
als ich mich damals von den pott weil
ein getrennter punkt an gesagt hab jetzt
muss ich was machen die funktions kind
wie warum dauert das manchmal so lange
bis sie wirklich
ich sag mal auf eigenen füßen stehen ihr
erstes album rausbringen
woran liegt das ich weiß nicht woran es
bei anderen liegt ich kann gleich keine
nummern erwähnt worden sie bei mir liegt
und was viele leute bei mir einfach
nicht mehr sehen ist ich weiß nicht wie
sie ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen
älter hausen ich gehöre zu den jüngsten
web man halt gerne game
ich glaube
einzig wieder noch jünger ist als ich es
nicht 57 und fh ist so glaube ich gleich
eigentlich wir waren damals angefangen
haben so die beiden 12 13 jährigen
retten haben und ja bei mir halt ich bin
sehr früh schon in dieses endes
reingerutscht und hätte mir heute
rückblickend er gewünscht dass ich die
zeit wo ich in dieses business schon
rutscht wird er genutzt hätte dafür
meine rap skillz aufzubessern an der
praxis zu arbeiten und dieses ganze als
geschäft erst viel später in betrieb
nehmen aber ich war sehr jung und habe
schon ein ding gemacht und war hungrig
und wollte machen und habe dann halt
auch sehr oft falsche entscheidungen
getroffen habe mich auch hier und da mal
aufgrund von naivität von gewissen
leuten ein bisschen verarschen lassen
sage ich mal beziehungsweise hinhalten
lassen und so ist es dazu gekommen dass
halt nie wirklich sich irgendwas bewegt
hat ja und dann war ich halt dann ein
punkt dass ich dann auch irgendwann mal
20 jahre alt war immer noch relativ jung
aber halt alt genug um ein bisschen
weiter zu denken und dann habe ich
gesagt okay entweder jetzt macht schon
sehr lange musik das war auch immer ein
traum gewesen du hast es nie richtig in
angriff genommen dass wir jetzt
irgendwie enttäuscht sein müsste ist
dass du noch nicht irgendwie bei drogen
bist aber bevor du aufhörst mit dem
ganzen probier's doch einmal richtig
dann habe ich es einmal richtig probiert
und dann nichts auf jeden fall
vernünftig so dass man eine basis und
eine zukunft darin erkennen kann ein
bisschen würdest du sagen ist dass übung
oder ist das talent oder was ist das
wichtigste was wir haben ein gewisses
grund talent muss schon dank danach muss
natürlich auch viel geübt werden und man
darf irgendwie nie von grund auf mit
sich selbst zufrieden sein man sollte
immer sehr perfektionistisch an die
sache rangehen
aber an sich ein grundmuster dann ich
sehe auch halt viele jungs auf der
straße die rollen rappen
aber dann kam es auch mal vor dass man
sich vielleicht mal eine umgebung eines
studios gesehen hatten dann läuft ein
beat und man den brauch kein
rhythmusgefühl taktgefühl wo muss ich
anfangs rappen und so was kannst du kein
beibringen da kannst du dir die haare
und vorsichtig fahren und das gab nicht
also dieses grund talent ein gewisses
verständnis für musik muss schon da sein
und den rest halt was rein technik und
verkettungen double time verstrickungen
und was weiß wie es geht
sowas kann man schon lernen lernen
deutschland erreicht das schwierige
frage also ich dabei wenn man goethe die
glocke durch nimmt oder schiller ich
sage ganz ehrlich ich sogar als künstler
der jetzt ein drittes album gemacht hat
bin jetzt gucke ich will jetzt nicht
irgendwie zu viel vorwegnehmen natürlich
bin ich noch nicht am ende meiner
karriere und plant schon nächste
projekte und dinge die ich in der
zukunft machen will
und jetzt bin ich an dem punkt
angekommen dass ich für meine planung
nicht nur jetzt texte schreiben und
bieten gerade sehen sondern gerade auch
wieder ein bisschen mehr bücher zu lesen
ja weil ich komme gerade an die grenzen
meines wortschatz ist mir auch gedacht
haben und ich glaube es wird zeigt man
wieder ein bisschen aufzufrischen also
ich denke natürlich literaturen
deutschunterricht und all das ist auf
jeden fall für web nichts schlechtes
weil wenn du irgendwann mal nicht nur
phrasen dreschen willst du nicht nur
wörter benutzen willst du schon hundert
mal benutzt dann merkst du das
wiederholen sich in den texten immer die
gleichen wörter und so man muss fit sein
muss viel lesen klar
meist benutzen zwar bei einer letzten
zeit ist mir oft aufgefallen dass ich
das wort profite meinen text delfin
benutze okay das ist mir wichtig dass er
das auseinander genommene profit und ja
da ist mir ein bisschen aufgefallen dass
wieder ein bisschen mehr sagt ja das
worauf man sich konzentriert dass wird
größer wie ist das mit dem profit kann
man davon leben oder wie stehst du noch
eine so im supermarkt kasse
insofern glaube ich stimme für immer
wenn wir einkaufen wollen ja aber ich
sag mal so
von der musik ich kam von der musik
leben gott sei dank nicht immer nicht
seit ich beschlossen habe das als
geschäft zu sehen habe ich direkt geld
verdienen das kein geld vom himmel
gefallen das erste album war noch viel
investitionen und plus minus null
rausholen gucken basis schaffen erst mal
stattfinden
das zweite album war viele investitionen
aber auch komplett wieder reinholen mit
gewinn
und jetzt seit dem dritten album
entsteht auch ein gewisses live geschäft
und wir haben mehr platten verkauft und
jetzt seid denn seit der dritten platte
kann ich auf jeden fall von der musik
leben und ich hoffe dass es so bleibt
was sagen deine eltern dazu gesagt zu
dem ganzen natürlich also dass so etwas
wollten einen eltern was du machst dir
an akademiker ich weiß was ja und bei
uns ist das schon haben halt geld dann
schon einen sehr hohen anspruch daran
dass ist die wiege der kultur extrem
riecht auch eine literatur sehr krass
ein goethe hat sich von einem aufseher
cross inspirieren lassen und ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen natürlich von meinen
so war immer ein sehr hoher anspruch
darüber dass das etwas was schon sehr
weit zurück hängt also jetzt
mittlerweile habe ich ein sehr
ausgeglichen ist und erwachsenes
verhältnis zu manager und ich lebe auf
eigentlichen dieb alleine und ich bin
ein mann jetzt mittlerweile respektieren
sie das und es kommt ja jetzt auch öfter
vor gerade bei den iranern bin jetzt
wenn ich sagen kann dass ich da bin dann
gerade bei den iranern soweit und
kriegen die natürlich auch mittlerweile
viel feedback so und
mein vater ist natürlich immer noch
kritisch und bringt ab und zu von links
und rechtsansprüche wenig meisten
besuchten weil meine mutter ist
mittlerweile stolz damals war das ein
sehr großer quatsch natürlich auch sehr
jung war ich hab vor jung und habe dinge
gefordert die ein anderer mein alter
englischer vom 12 13
auf der straße wegen rap bis nachts
james may was hat ein was hat auch schon
james damals um 12 13 jähriger zu suchen
war es doch wohl nur gekifft und
gesoffen und gekocht wird und ja ich war
unterwegs und ich wollte das machen und
ich habe kriege zu hause geführt
und irgendwann hat musik halt auch
wirklich dein gebracht dass ich auch
persönlich mit meinem leben in eine
gewisse waren gerutscht in der ich
eigentlich in die hätte landen müssen
von zu hause aus ja ich habe auch einen
älteren bruder
gott sei dank auf den vernünftigen weg
ist jetzt bald sein medizinstudium
beendet ich bin auch sehr stolz auf ihn
und beim jesus halt anders gelaufen und
ich will nicht die musik hat viel
positives in mein leben bewirkt gerade
jetzt bewegt sich auch viel positives
weil nach dem leben was ich jetzt gelebt
habe hält mich die musik davon ab
komplett in diese schiene zu rutschen
er hat mich davon abgehalten die letzten
jahre und aber ich muss halt dazu auch
sagen dass musik auch ein zwei negative
sachen hervorgerufen hat und zwar meine
berührung mit der straße und mit diesen
mit den ersten kontakten werden deinen
weg dann halt dahin verleiten dass es
bei mir durch musik passiert nichts
anderes ist da würdest du sagen ich bin
da auf die schiefe bahn
was heißt auf die schiene das habe ich
das ich hätte durch musik nicht auf die
schiefe bahn
irgendwie landen müssen die sache ist
halt nur jeder mensch hat seine eigene
psyche ich war halt relativ jung und
durch die musik hat sich halt meine
erste berührung damit jeder mensch ist
dann selber überlassen was er daraus
macht ob er dann sagt eine scheiß drauf
das nicht mein ding oder ja ich will das
und ich war ja ich will das und dann was
hat doch nichts mit musik zu tun hat
und das muss man halt auch sinn ich habe
mittlerweile man hat ja ein rap game
viele fans und gleichzeitig viele hater
und
ich mache halt ich will jetzt nicht
irgendwie ich bin eigentlich
bescheidener typ aber so ich bin
überzeugt davon dass ich gerade was web
angeht sehr gut bin musikalisch es gibt
halt viele rapper die stattfinden mit
allem anderen alles anderes daraus gute
musik und bei mir stimmt halt die musik
nur was die sache ist bei mir halt das
ding für mich war ich hab das halt
verinnerlicht komplett zur esse ich habe
mein ding gemacht
ich bin es gerade raus ich habe direkt
die nächste frage mich interessiert du
sagst jetzt ich hab' das gewusst ich bin
in diese richtung musik aber du hast ja
vorhin beschrieben damit fahren auch
großen töpfen und sonstwas verbunden
habe ich nicht gemacht dann mit yui hast
du das denn trennen können die so bis
ich sag mal du bist 12 du bist damit
deutlich älteren zusammen wir ja mit
sicherheit seine vorbilder waren die
hatte das treffen können ein stabiler
charakter
damals war erstmal wollte habe ich
wusste ich noch dass das nicht erlaubt
ist das was nicht gut ist aber dann mit
14 15
finde ich auch an gewisse sachen
ausprobieren und genau jetzt bin ich
wieder da wo ich jetzt bin ich wieder da
wo ich eigentlich vorher wollte sie sagt
ich krieg wenn ich irgendwie haye zu
spüren bekommen zurzeit dann kommt daher
dass leute sagen der junge rappt schon
der rap schon sehr lange und wie gesagt
ich war jung ich habe mein ding gemacht
ich hab rap gemacht aber dann habe ich
mit wem man wie heiß nicht abgebrochen
aber es wurde weniger ok und
die dinge die ich halt draußen in meinem
leben so gemacht haben überhand gewonnen
dass ich halt an einem punkt wo ich
schon nach eco und wo ich schon bei
crazy kids im juli war mit manuellsen
schon wirklich musik machen darunter
deutschland mich auch schon ein bisschen
kannte vom namen her
also man wusste womit man mich
assoziiert und der name war im begriff
zu dieser zeit habe ich gesagt scheiße
auf rap und habe drei jahre lang was
komplett anderes gemacht
es ist jetzt keine doch dumme frage ist
ja schon im rahmen der
wahrscheinlichkeit
wenn ich wenn du mir die frage soll ich
machen muss ich erst mal mein gott
kleinen sagen um erst mal korrekt zu
wirken
ja natürlich ich habe drei jahre lang
hat das gemacht was ein jugendlicher auf
der straße gemacht die einfach mit einem
brüche an
bei den anderen beginnen die ersten
berührungen mit der straße irgendwie
durch grafiken und deshalb macht das war
das einfach irgendwann mal geht's halt
nicht nur darum irgendwann wenn du etwas
machst es ist auch nicht nur spaß am
anfang ist es spaß am anfang ist es
witzig einmal von alexander pitz vom
gymnasium
aber irgendwas mit dem bösen buben zu
tun aus der stadt und dann entwickelt es
sich alles weiter und irgendwann mal
entwickelt sich dein leben halt wirklich
in diese kreise
das ist halt auch irgendwann nicht mehr
irgendein trend war und ist dass uns
gibt es im film knallhart weil sich
optisch hat sich leider nicht gesehen
david kross wo er am schluss einen
seiner konkurrenten erschießt ist das so
hart gibt es ja diese drogenbosse die
diese absolute macht haben drogenbosse
die absolut gleichmäßig dass
irgendwelche leute gibt die irgendwelche
massenmorde beauftragen wie ein
amerikanischer film so ist es nicht aber
es ist auch nicht so dass irgendwelche
ist lernen und lesen natürlich viel von
leuten die halt ein globales
mittelständiges leben leben und mit so
etwas nicht zu tun
es gibt so was gar nicht in deutschland
und doch natürlich gibts sowas und in
dem metier in dem ich mich lange bewegt
habe passiert passieren todesfälle durch
messerstiche oder schüsse oder so locker
elf mal im jahr
das heißt wie sie durch die alte mann
der das ist unterschiedlich 51 in
welchem weg man sich entscheiden kann
17 passieren kann mit 20 passieren kann
mit 35 passieren kann auch gar nicht
passieren am ende des tages gottes wege
sind unergründlich und ich bin halt auch
ein bisschen größer und ich denke für
uns alle steht dem moment schon fest so
aber ist natürlich passieren solche
dinge und es gibt doch es gibt menschen
auf der straße die eine gewisse macht
pflegen das sieht man auch mittlerweile
immer mehr nachrichten in deutschland
wäre und man sieht auch dass deutschland
sich immer mehr immer mehr so entwickelt
irgendwann ein paar jahren so zu sein
wie paris dann vorbei an war
paris frankreich weise es wird auch hier
immer heftiger ganz klar man sieht das
doch auch in den nachrichten wie viel
was da alles passiert mit
motorradclubs und anderen straßen
gruppierungen und all das dass es alle
salonfähig geworden in deutschland das
ist ganz normal und es passiert und es
entwickelt sich weiter und es da ist
auch kein ende in sicht
du hast sich aber dagegen entschieden
was heißt dagegen entschieden ab
die meisten freunde die ich bin niemand
der dann sagt von heute auf morgen
spielen was besseres als ihr alle
freunde dich von damals hatte hatte ich
habe ich habe ich habe ich immer noch
aber ich habe mich für die musik
entschieden ich habe mich dafür
entschieden eine eine gewisse linie zu
setzen und auch zum glück freunde die
mich respektieren und nicht freunden die
mich noch unter runden runter drücken
wollen wie es bei vielen rappern in
deutschland mit ihren freunden so ist
bei mir ist es nicht so meine freunde
respektieren mich und wenn ich sage ich
mache mein ding und ich probiere jetzt
gerade eine perspektive zu entwicklung
entscheide mich er dafür in den nächsten
jahren entscheide mich in den nächsten
jahren eher für karriere und familie
statt für respekt und gefängnis dann
sagen meine freunde bruder wenn du diese
entscheidung trifft dann wäre ich nicht
dein freund wenn ich dich da wenig
unterstützen würde
und ich kann trotzdem abends mit denen
am ende des tages irgendwann um 83 sack
abends bei einem türken sitzen und was
essen und auch mit deren unterhaltung
anhören und vielleicht auch mal einen
tipp geben als außenstehender und die
auch mal vielleicht wieder ein bisschen
runter uns überhaupt kein problem
versuchst du denn sie davon überzeugen
was anderes zu machen oder redet man
nicht
doch durch gespräche gibt es mal hin und
wieder das passiert immer wenn man wenn
nach zwei drei wochen irgendwas bei
denen explodiert und einer voll kopf
geschickt dann natürlich passiert es mal
dass ich auch sagen warum eigentlich das
alles ja aber am ende des tages sind
meine freunde auch alles männer die
erwachsen sind und für sich selber
stehen und die haben sich für diesen weg
entschieden und ich respektiere das auch
wenn sich jemand für sie
weg entscheidet werde wenn das
vernünftig macht nicht wie ein kleiner
kleiner junge wer rausgeht und auf
einmal aufgrund irgendein
minderwertigkeitskomplex ein gangster
sein will wenn sie sagen dass es unser
ding wir wollen das machen dann macht
das ok no risk no fun
aber trage die konsequenzen wenn es
genannt so ist das wenn du im knast
landet heute nicht wie eine tussi würde
ich jetzt sagen wenn es wenn du draußen
den dicken machst und dinge macht und
jemanden aus einer familie was passiert
heute nicht geheuer aber so sagen ja
warum besteht sowohl du hast dich für
diesen weg entschieden
und wer sich für diesen weg entscheiden
kann der kann halt aber dein weg ist für
dich der besser natürlich ich habe eine
verländerung soll ich das nicht
ausnutzen dass das meinte heute musik
halt auch wieder viel positives für mich
weil wenn jetzt auf der anderen seite
die musik nicht da gewesen wäre hätte
ich mich vielleicht auch kompletter
entschieden
du erzählst du auf deinem album zwei
geschichten die eine ist matschig die
andere ist flashback eigentlich sind die
beiden pole ein
der eine ist der geht quasi den falschen
weg aber eigentlich geht da genau den
gleichen weg den du in flashbacks
flashback zur info ist dass es quasi
deine geschichte dritte jugendmannschaft
ist die geschichte eines jungen der geht
diesen weg oder scheitert du bist den
weg gegangen
du hast erfolg gehabt er hatte ich habe
halt ein bisschen mit rap dann halt
daheim gearbeitet am ende des songs
macht ist der unterschied und manche 30
halt wirklich für den kriminellen weg
entschieden hat halt kein musikalisches
talent deshalb komplett für die
kriminalität entschieden und gott
bewahre natürlich auch fleisch
wm-abschied geworden
die musik nicht dagewesen wäre ich mache
ja und das auch eine wahre geschichte
ich habe jetzt nicht die echten namen
benutzt das eine geschichte über einen
jungen der auch bei uns aus essen kommt
und ja herzlich für diesen weg
entschieden
er war eigentlich auch jemand aus einem
iranischen haushalt akademisch
aufgewachsene diesem weg hätten gehen
müssen aber halt irgendwann mal den
geltungsdrang weil es auch von zu hause
aus nicht gut ging und die heutzutage
existieren halt nur noch diese
statussymbole und werte dickes auto
putzen frauen ja und er wollte auch und
hertz auch gemacht und erfolgreich
gemacht und der bauch und übte sich
durchgesetzt hatte hatte er in der hose
aber er hat sogar genauso wie ich einen
älteren bruder
der halt auch komplett auf dem normalen
weg war und auch gar nichts wusste von
all dem was er gemacht hatten eines
tages mal irgendwelche leute die in
abziehen wollten vor seiner haustür
haben sein bruder erwischt die sich auch
eigentlich relativ ähnlich sein
der bruder wussten nicht was los war
kennt diese welt auch gar nicht weiß
auch gar nicht dass da eine reale gefahr
existiert
er lässt sich auf ein streit mit diesen
jungs ein und die stechen ab mitten ins
herz
sowas passiert und das meine ich gefragt
was sie alles sind dinge die passieren
alltäglich in allen städten deutschlands
obwohl es dann bald jeder punkt gewesen
wo du hast gecheckt hast du gesagt hast
ne hier ist eine weggabelung und ich geh
jetzt vielleicht im wahrsten sinne des
wortes den rechten weg
es gibt verschiedene punkte natürlich
war ein wichtiger punkt bei mir wo ich
dann das erste mal nur aufgenommen und
alten großen prozess hatte so wirklich
auch mit einem blauen auge davonkam und
gott sei dank eine bewährungsstrafe
bekommen im straße bewährungsstrafe
bekommen die jetzt gott sei dank in
fünf monaten zu ende ist nach zwei
jahren
das war ein bestandteil von dem was mich
dazu gebracht hat aber der verschiedene
punkte sind auch verschiedene dinge halt
passieren
schlüsselerlebnis ein schlüsselerlebnis
wo du sagst das war so der erste schritt
oder das war vielleicht das finale
dieser entwicklung wo ich dachte was die
u haft oder eigentlich sagen nehmen
das war schon nach dem wurde ich sehr
ruhig ich bin langsam langsam ruhiger
geworden und habe die musik angefangen
habe eigentlich gar nicht gesagt ich bin
jetzt weg davon das hat sich dann
irgendwann dahin entwickelt um eine
persönlichkeit hat sich auch ein
bisschen verändert so dass ich
irgendwann auch ein bisschen abkühlen
halb geschoben habe auf etwas aber wie
soll ich sagen
dazu komme ich gleich noch mal die sache
ist halt dass viele schlüssel erlebnisse
gewesen sind immer stück für stück als
ich 15 16 jahre alt war das auch ein
guter freund von mir damals mit meinem
cousin zufällig bin ich einfach nicht
rausgegangen sind auch irgendwo
rumgelaufen wollten was weiß ich auf
einem spielplatz in joint rauchen oder
so ist streit entstanden mit
irgendjemandem und jemand durch den
damals bekannten messer gezogen und den
wenigen abgestochen
an dem tag für zwölf jahren haft
geahndet und das bis heute auch mal
geschossen gefängnis raus das mit meiner
eigenen inhaftierung und auch die taten
nicht davor begangen habe ich war damals
halt auch eine zeitlang im jahr 2009 wo
ich schon als web aktiv war nachdem ich
mit casey apple schon ein album release
hatte damals offiziell im handel und
dann irgendwie komplett abgedriftet
bildung gar keine musik mehr gemacht hat
sich auch gezeigt wo ich sehr aggressiv
war
wo ein typ mir dann damals geld
geschuldet hat und ich etwas sehr
schlimmes mit ihm gemacht habe so
daraufhin gab es diese
auseinandersetzungen
vor allem in mülheim an der ruhr wo auf
mich geschossen wurde
das sind viele dinge passiert die mich
einfach dahin gebracht haben dass ich
gesagt habe
willst du dass dir selber und deiner
familie antun und musst du es überhaupt
bei dem können und auch bei dem
hintergrund den hass welche so ich habe
ein gewisses köpfchen mit herz auf der
straße gibt es viele menschen die auch
wirklich skrupellos handeln und die
einer von diesen komplett skrupellosen
bei schnee dann immer jemand der sein
herz am rechten fleck bewahrt hat so
seinen glauben bewahrt und ich habe mich
einfach irgendwann hat sich dahin
entwickelt werden und jetzt wenn ich
jetzt album herausbringe wo ich sogar
ein paar straßen rapper dizzee und sage
dass ich kotzen bei euch ist das ist
daraus entstanden dass ich zum
abgeschoben habe als ich gesehen habe
dass ich halt so eine base im deutschen
hiphop entwickelt hat das auf einmal so
alle 14 bis 16 jährigen kann man
angefangen haben web zu hören und aber
gar nichts mit dieser musik voll zu tun
gehabt haben das einfach nur als
plattform sehen und bei facebook
irgendwelche leute zu beleidigen und das
total nur noch das war einfach alles
noch stumpf ich habe gesehen um für mich
war diese musik halt immer mehr gewesen
ich mache immer noch straßenrap so weil
viele leute verwechseln das jetzt manche
konnten zum beispiel nicht verstehen
dass ich irgendwelche newcomer rappern
wie 145 oder kunde oder so probst auf
meine feier sowas immer noch meetings
und ich mache es auch zum teil noch
selber mir ging es halt wirklich darum
dass ein gewisses mit ihr und eine
gewisse base die daraus entstanden ist
geht mir auf den sack wo ich einfach
gesagt was
das ist dieses wie soll ich sagen viele
rapper sind zurzeit abgefuckt auf
facebook ob bushido ich ganz so viel
aufsehen
und weil wirklich sehr vielen
vollidioten eine meinung gegeben wurde
durch diese sozialen netzwerke natürlich
augen natürlich angesehen werde ich
natürlich auch anonym sind und ich muss
sagen dass diese vollidioten vor diesen
rappern gar kein deutschen web gehört
haben nichts mit uns zu tun wenn die
wahren weg von uns werden sie ein fan
von und man muss halt diesen kids doch
zeigen also das ist nicht nur die ich
fick dich und wenn du willst gangster
seien meinetwegen du willst du sein
willst sein hat sein ist nicht einfach
wie ein vollidiot den ganzen tag zu
fluchen
ich kenne harte typen die sind schon
über 30 jahre alt die haben sehr viel
auf dem kerbholz aber die reden nicht so
reden wie erwachsene männer und einfach
dass auch in diesen straßen mit der
komplett falsche werte vermittelt wurden
das einfach gesagt hat wenn das gangster
ist wenn das hart ist und wenn das geld
dann bin ich nicht mehr gangster seien
noch nicht mehr geld doch nicht mehr
hart sein
das ist für mich kindisch das ist für
mich lächerlich und und ich weiß auch
wie so viele straßen läuft das auch
nicht hart und deswegen habe ich dann
angefangen gewisse dinge zu kritisieren
und meine meinung zu sagen okay und hass
befürchtet du nicht dass das dann wieder
die aggression im ganzen business nach
oben treibt und das nie endet ist doch
machen wir am ende des tages soll es
doch auch die leute ein bisschen
entertain
ich sehe es auf die musikalische basis
ich bin kein ich bin keiner von denen
gesagt kommt wir treffen uns jetzt
müssen uns gegenseitig ab ich bin nur
einer von denen er sagt wenn ihr
unbedingt wollte kommt ich verstecke
mich nicht für euch weil es diese
politik für andere rapper in deutschland
leider gottes fahren die nicht mal
selber gefahren werden immer von anderen
menschen gefahren
und ja für mich ist das alles red für
mich ist es gab paar rapper die habe ich
in ihrem rap abgefragt und ich komme aus
der zeit wo ein rapper ein rapper wissen
konnte dafür verstöße das ist einfach
das ding heutzutage muss ein rapper erst
was mit meiner frau gehabt haben oder
muss mir mein geld geklaut haben dass
ich eine berechtigung habe ihn zu wissen
ich lese immer so schön unter diesem
unter diesen 100 bars video zum beispiel
lese ich immer so was hat er denn getan
dass ein ende gesetzt hat hat mir gar
nichts getan er hat scheiße gereckt er
hat etwas scheiße nach aus und
vermittelt ich bin rapper wir begeben
uns in oft in diesem spielfeld begegnen
wir uns einander verstehst und wenn er
mich in diesem spielfeld abwarten bis
ich ihn er muss mir persönlich nichts
getan haben ich habe auch persönlich
gegen niemanden etwas aber diese leute
sind leider leider leider sehr komplex
beladen wollen ist immer dann auf die
persönliche ebene treiben und das ist
etwas was ich absolut nicht
nachvollziehen kann aber wo ich dann
halt auch sage okay seid herzlich
willkommen ich bin niemand der sich nach
unten treten lässt oder da sagt der sich
von euren straßen film beeindruckend ist
hier bin ich ich poste auch voll auf
meine adresse einfach und sagt kommt
aber wie kommt irgendjemand das ist
unfassbar
die reaktion von dem ist anscheinend
echt aber jedes mal wenn ich meine
adresse post merke ich dass nur
entertaining ist deswegen entertaining
ist und deswegen ist auch alles cool wie
gesagt für mich immer nur musik gewesen
ich würde mich freuen wenn ich einer von
denen zurück dessen bildung wie man also
ein schönes gentleman battle wieder in
deutschland hätten wo man einfach geiles
fonds kommen ich kann mich noch erinnern
kann gab sauber und schöne sachen damals
aber damals wo ecke und den konflikt
hatten sei mal dahin gestellt was da
jetzt alles passiert ist aber das war
eine zeitlang deutschen kochen und ich
finde das geil da war auch jetzt nicht
unbedingt gefahr dass ihnen jemand
abgeknallt wird muss doch nicht
passieren da sind in der zeit von
ungefähr was weiß ich zehn elf songs
gekommen die alles zerstört haben und
jeder wand und ist doch cool aber die
leute haben zurzeit werden
heute tagen stockemer statistischen so
fressen wenn ich den nicht auf die
fresse gehauen haben dann denke meine
fans schwingt ein gangster ist ihnen ein
echter gangster dies doch nicht aber du
bist doch ein rapper darauf zu wetten
was macht sie verschießt das ist ein
bisschen mein statement ich bin halt was
die musik wieder angelangt ein bisschen
zu meinen wurzeln zurückgekehrt die vor
der straße gewesen sind und deswegen
gerade deswegen weil ich halt schon
stattfinde so ein bisschen in der
öffentlichkeit seitdem ich 15 bin gibt
es auch viele songs form jetzt den ich
heute nicht mehr stehen kann
in einer zeit entstanden sind wo ich
noch jung war und mich gerade selber
finden würde aber jetzt habe ich mich
selbst gefunden und das bin ich und ich
werde auch morgen nicht wieder mit total
über krass und gangsterrap anfangen das
was ich mache das alles real alles im
rahmen
ich berichte ich erzähle dinge aus
meinem leben ich mache auch gerne dinge
die bisher positive laune machen
mittlerweile und nach vorne gehen und
erzählt von der straße aber alles halt
gesagt okay im rahmen das hoffen wir mal
dass alles im rahmen bleibt
ok nein genf